welcome to folding ideas in the final
installment of man Media movie month
this week we're going to take a look at
a man's man's man among every men a man
so man that he could only be the
embodiment of satire in cartoon form
it's Homer Simpson of course
Homer Simpson is a character who doesn't
need much if any introduction at this
point The Simpsons has been on the air
since 1989 an entire generation of
people has grown to adulthood in a post
Simpsons world the show is so culturally
ubiquitous that references to the
characters are often made without
contextualization basically the Simpsons
are the yardstick that we use to
contextualise everything else so let's
talk about it something that I haven't
really addressed yet this month is the
importance of tone in all of this we
grazed across it last time when talking
about 300 but this is a good time to
take a longer look at it Homer Simpson
is a terrible person he's a
simple-minded buffoon characterized by
indolence stupidity gluttony and greed
he's not only ignorant and lazy but
proud of his ignorance and defensive of
his laziness so how do I think I can get
away with talking about him in a
positive way when I spent an entire
episode talking about how bad Sam
Witwicky is well it's tone The Simpsons
is satirical comedy in essence Homer is
already a critical look at male persona
in culture and media showing off the
double standard in gender roles and low
expectations of males in society the
entire point of satire is to stand
something up and mock it in an attempt
at shaming society into reform we're
supposed to look at Homer and go oh geez
are we really this stupid
Homer mocks old people and we're
supposed to feel bad about our abuses of
the elderly Oh dad you've done a lot of
great things but you're a very old man
now and old people are useless
Homer treats his failings as
accomplishments and we're supposed to
feel bad about our own complacency
whoa look at that lover fly homer abuses
his power and we're supposed to feel bad
about our own power mongering well what
do you say to the accusation that your
group has been causing more crimes than
it's been preventing Oh Ted I'd be lying
if I said my men weren't committing
crimes the only problem is that Homer is
trapped in a tangled web of recursive
influence the first part of the problem
is one that all satire faces and that's
well it's that no matter how extreme you
make your satire someone is going to
agree with what you say and not what you
mean this isn't a new problem in the
classic example would be Jonathan
Swift's a modest proposal published in
1729 is a satire on the racism naivety
and excesses of the aristocracy a modest
proposal suggests that the best way to
take care of the poor in ireland would
be to let the irish sell their children
as food to the rich in england but some
people took it seriously heck some
people still take it seriously today now
as far as I know no one actually sold
Irish babies as food but the challenge
with satire is that it's a giant in joke
if you don't know that it's satire then
you're going to miss the point here's
where Homer comes in how many people in
the audience actually get it I don't
have numbers but I would suggest that a
significant portion missed the point
because the Simpsons completely reshaped
primetime programming with piles upon
piles of imitation shows that glorified
fat Slaven wee male characters without
the satirical condemnation same hour ago
the cubs were losing and I put my foot
on the table and Ramirez hit a home on
and that's how the loop formed one of
the big problems that The Simpsons has
faced post 2000 is that it's become a
show satirizing a world that it has
itself completely redefined
the world accepted the Simpsons what had
previously been a counterculture jab at
the mainstream had not only become part
of the mainstream but had completely
redefined it this forced the Simpsons to
shift with the characters becoming more
exaggerated and reflective of the world
that was changing around them to the
point that the Homer of today is very
different from the Homer the show
started out with oh sure he's still a
continuous character
but he's shifted a lot I never thought
of fatherhood is something I could
affect a kid personally I like to define
it as two distinct character shifts one
very early in the show's history and the
other a more gradual shift in the late
90s
Homer started off as a riff on the
father knows best type sitcom males that
were prevalent from the 50s through the
80s in particular the Simpsons as a
whole was a riff on The Cosby Show where
the Huxtables were well off the Simpsons
were in perpetual debt where dr.
Huxtable had a good job as a
self-employed dentist Homer was an
incompetent cog in the machine in
contrast to the tolerant wise
good-natured and long-suffering fathers
of other sitcoms Homer was impatient
easily influenced short-tempered vice
ridden and generally incompetent but at
his core Homer was still a good person
just a good person stuck in bad
circumstances then around the middle of
the second season they changed Homer see
the Cosby shows template was old and
already beginning to fade being replaced
with sitcoms like Roseanne and Family
Matters focusing on working-class
families through this shift
Homer became simpler funnier and more
marketable but less moral and perhaps
less interesting Homer went from this
dad how come we can't get a decent move
like the Flanders have just be happy
with what you've got son don't try to
keep up with the Flanders to this Hey
stop Kevin stop
what a you won I won free cable
somewhere in there homers good side died
leaving only his vices to dance on top
of the grave it's true we have proof I
am evil homer i am evil homer it was a
good business decision as it turned out
to be generally funnier to have Homer
start off clearly in the wrong then
slowly learn a hard lesson by the end of
the episode that's an important point
it's gonna come up later so I want you
to remember it Homer would start off
doing something incredibly selfish and
stupid but Lisa or Marge or someone
would get him back on track by the end
of the episode he steals cable but at
the end of the episode he personally
cuts the wire so that said here's where
everything just kind of goes off the
rails in the late 90s through the mid
part of the first decade of the 2000s
that we don't have a good name for my
friend Brenda says that they call it the
aughts back in the 1900s who chase the
Irish out of Springfield village not far
there was this huge shift in sitcoms
exploiting the Homer formula according
to Jim Family Guy rounded for life still
standing King of Queens this list goes
on now I'm not just talking about the
fat guy hot wife set up for one Marge
isn't that attractive even if she is
skinny and for two Simpsons was far from
the first to use that set up now what
i'm talking about is the
characterization the guy is fat stupid
and the main character we as an audience
are trained to accept the actions of the
main character to root for them and want
them to succeed so the tone of The
Simpsons worked against it
comedy made it easy to accept Homer
instead of condemning him because come
on how bad can he be if he makes us
laugh everyone latched on to the part
where Homer steals cable and skipped the
part where he cuts the wire himself
leaving us with a trend of terrible
shows of a lazy fat man who took pride
in their ignorance and rejection of
culture and growth same hour ago the
cubs were losing and I put my foot on
the table and Ramirez hit a home on in a
response to this Homer had to shift even
further satirizing how TV had taken to
treating stupid and mean as acceptable
whoa
good things do happen to fat people so
what conclusions can we draw from this
and how does it
fit into our running theme well it's the
culture is large frustrating complicated
and there are no simple easy answers I
wish I could ball it all up and shove it
in a box that I could hand over and say
here you go here's the problem here's
the solution but well I can't I'm well
I'm I'm sorry if that's unsatisfying Oh
good things do happen to good people